dancing with the stars deliver  show-stopping routines on night one of  the finale as Mark Ballas gets emotional  and ginger Zee makes a recovery how's it  feeling it feels good I'm sorry but it  feels good feels good and looks good  ginger Zee stunned with this  contemporary dance and later with a  Ginger Rogers inspired freestyle  I'm so happy that we got through it we  did it Paige Vanzant salsa went off  without a hitch  I was very nervous and just more excited  to get my to go out there and dance but  it was her heartfelt freestyle that  brought her partner Mark Ballas to tears  I'm so proud of this girl far she's come  she's completely open to opened up I'm  not really a crier that there's a B  right now Paige now we're moving as one  the dance how excellent she executed it  everything just I don't know just all  the right things happen at once and I  just got a picture